le mauvais temps qui a régné sur les
côtes de la méditerranée ces dernières
semaines a gravement endommagé une
partie de la côte espagnole la costa
brava aux alentours de barcelone mais
aussi plus bas vers le sud la région de
valence des plages ont été dévastés par
les tempêtes tout cela à la veille de
l'ouverture de la saison touristique
reportage karine comazzi françoise maso
une baleine de 15 mètres échoué dans le
port de barcelone
c'est dire la force de la tempête qui
s'est abattue sur le littoral espagnol
pendant le week-end de l'ascension de
barcelone à valence les plages
méditerranéennes ont pris des allures de
mer du nord
ici dans la capitale catalane les plages
artificielles qui bordent la ville ont
été littéralement déplacer et moss
perdido refrain la nature mais nous
n'avons pas plus 48 mille mètres cubes
un pêcheur ces infrastructures ont été
touchés également des passerelles des
douches des tours de sécurité plus grave
c'est la perte de sales draps geha
mètres cubes de sable coûte 100 euros
l'acheter en vaut le double au total la
municipalité va devoir convaincre l'état
espagnol de débourser plusieurs millions
d'euros pour que les plages soient
prêtes pour la haute saison
à un mois de l'échéance le quartier du
port olympique construit pour les jeux
de 92 inspire plutôt la désolation
c'est toujours comme ça quand on fait de
grandes organisations internationales où
se lève et dise mon naturel de
vieillissement naturel en voisinage avec
le bord de la mer ce soir
le produit de matériaux très corrosif à
cause du seul de l'ambiance saleh
le long de la plage de boga deuil de la
plus prisée des barcelonais les
restaurateurs 5e
normalement un samedi comme aujourd'hui
le restaurant le plein de monde il ya
des gens qui attendent eux mêmes leur
devoir manger maintenant avec tout ce
qui s'est passé regarder on n'y a
pratiquement personne
j'espère qu'ils vont refaire à maarten
parce que c'est plus pratique fait que
le plus pratique pour l'eau puisque
j'habite centre-ville de patronne des
ramblas aux allures londonienne faute de
soleil les touristes auront trouvé ce
week end à barcelone un certain
dépaysement